[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poils et à
plumes s'immisce plume il nous revenons
aujourd'hui avec un nouveau sujet
passionnant pour ce qui fait la bestiole
mais avant de commencer je me dois de
vous prévenir cette fois ci c'est le
plus me qui a choisi la vidéo à traiter
et non ce n'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle
petit récapitulatif rapide pour les
nouveaux venus sur la chaîne les kékés
fait la bestiole sont des mini format où
vous devez jouer les apprentis éthologue
et analyser la vidéo que je vous propose
pour comprendre ce qu'il s'y passe alors
ne vous inquiétez pas il ne s'agit pas
de faire une dissertation complète
simplement de répondre à un qcm en
milieu de vidéos on ne vous demandera
rien de plus promis aujourd'hui je vous
emmène à la découverte de rapaces nord
américain je ne vous en dis pas plus à
leur sujet car leur identification en
soi offre déjà une partie de la réponse
si vous voulez trouver la bonne réponse
au quiz je vous encourage donc fortement
à trouver de quelle espèce sont les deux
oiseaux que vous verrez dans la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à la mettre sur pause au
besoin pour mieux les observer votre
défi aujourd'hui serait de comprendre
l'interaction entre ces deux rapaces je
vous laisse découvrir la vidéo et on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
non
et voici maintenant l'heure des quiz
j'espère que vous avez bien analysé la
vidéo car cette fois ci il n'est pas
facile
la grande question est donc aimé
quelques faits la bestiole réponse à le
jeune oiseau couvre la proie a mené par
un adulte
réponse b le mâle offre un poisson à la
femelle c'est la parade nuptiale
réponse ces legs la tête blanche vient
de se faire voler son poisson par un
autre aigle cdu kleptocratie tisme
réponse des legs lebrun à commander et
peyrefiche le service de livraison pour
les aigles moderne et voilà donc je vous
laisse y réfléchir et en attendant je
vous remet la vidéo
alors comme à chaque fois prenez bien
garde au détail c'est ce qui vous
permettra de déterminer ce qu'il se
passe réellement
on se retrouve juste après pour la
réponse
[Musique]
et voilà revenu devant ce quiz et
j'espère que vous avez trouvé la bonne
réponse
si on vous avait encore besoin de
délibérer n'hésitez pas à mettre la
vidéo en pause parce que je vais
maintenant vous révéler la solution
la bonne réponse était la réponse à
bravo à ceux qui avaient trouvé il n'y
avait plusieurs indices dans la vidéo
qui pouvait vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille et tout d'abord la coloration
des deux oiseaux ces deux rapaces sont
des pygargues à tête blanche des animaux
de la famille des aigles et des bus qui
mangent principalement du poisson
d'ailleurs cette espèce de pygargues ne
doit pas vous être inconnu car il s'agit
ni plus ni moins que de l'emblème des
usa le fameux bandit go et là vous allez
me dire un média qu'un seul pygargue à
tête blanche sur cette vidéo la tête de
l'autre est complètement drones alors
effectivement la tête de l'autre oiseaux
et brunes pourtant il s'agit tout de
même d'un pygargue à tête blanche mais
cette fois ci d'un juvénile en effet les
jeunes pygargues ne développe un plumage
adultes qu'après leur cinquième
anniversaire mes plumes blanches
apparaissent petit à petit au cours des
cinq premières années jusqu'à recouvrir
entièrement à la tête de l'oiseau et
c'est pour cela que nous pouvons en
déduire qu'il s'agit d'un jeune de
l'année
sur la vidéo c'était le premier indice
de cette vidéo
pour ce qui est du second vingt dix
regardez le sol sous les serres de
l'aigle
il s'agit d'une ère c'est le nom qu'on
donne uni de l'aigle c'est une
plateforme fait de branchages souvent
très grande qui peut se trouver au
sommet d'un arbre ou sur une corniche
rocheuses ici donc on est en période de
reproduction vu que le pigalle occupe
son lit il est donc plus que probable
que toute la scène et à voir avec un
comportement visible pendant la saison
de reproduction
un troisième indice le cri de l'aiglon
les aigles et les pygargues à cri de la
sorte parce qu'ils sont excités et c'est
notamment le cas des petits lorsque les
parents rentrent au nid pour les nourrir
l'un des parents rapporte un poisson
qu'il a péché à son petit poisson que
l'on voit ici avant que le jeune
pygargues ne s'en saisisse pour d'accord
c'est un peu rapide
si vous n'avez pas vu le poisson ce
n'est pas bien grave de toute façon
parce que ce dernier indice devrait
pouvoir vous montrer qu'il y à bien la
nourriture en jeu le jeune fille gamme
une fois le poisson attrapé déploie ses
ailes dans un mouvement qu'on appelle
couvrir ou mantelet c'est un terme de
fauconnerie pour dire qu un rapace
recouvre sa proie de ses ailes comme
d'un manteau dans le but de la protéger
d'autres prédateurs qui pourrait venir
lui piquer son pas durement acquis ici
même sens bien voir le poisson
il est facile de comprendre que les
glands protège son repas grâce à cette
posture bien particulière les ailes
écartées contre le sol alors vous allez
me dire c'est un peu bizarre de protéger
le poisson dans cette situation
après tout il lui a été donnée par ses
parents c'est pas comme s'il allait lui
reprendre mais il faut bien garder en
tête que le jeune oiseau d'une est
particulièrement excités à la vue de son
repas et que donc instinctivement et va
utiliser un comportement adapté à la
situation
et de deux il faut qu'ils apprennent ces
comportements qu'ils sachent les
utiliser avant de quitter le nid c'est
une sorte d'entraînement pour plus tard
quand il devra chasser lui-même sa
nourriture et la protéger pour la manger
tranquillement un dernier point
importante d'ailleurs c'est la réaction
du parent face à l'agressivité de son
petit 1 autres rapaces aurait
certainement attaquer après s'être fait
voler son poisson ou bien aurait au
moins exprimer son mécontentement
ici le parent se contente d'observer son
petit pendant quelques instants
vérifiant qu'il a bien pris le poisson
puis s'en va sans montrer aucune
agressivité
ce comportement plutôt passif confirme
ainsi que nous avons affaire à un parent
et à son jeune et voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui
si vous avez des idées de vidéos à
traiter laissez-moi les liens dans les
commentaires et je les ajouterait à la
liste de celles que j'ai déjà et qui
sait ce sera peut-être le sujet du
prochain café la bestiole
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures avec
des plumes
[Musique]
à